we're here in lindale with 37 Nobel
prize-winning scientist 600 young
researchers 12 of them sponsored by Mars
and people want to hear all about the
science that Mars has been doing well
the great thing about coming to lindale
is that we get to spend time with
sciences rock stars you aware that
you're in the presence of greatness in
the more that we can find ways of
engaging some of the finest minds in the
world to helping us solve some of these
grand challenges and then there's got to
be some great stuff in
one of the things we do is we like to
have a lunch where we basically spend
time with the young scientists that
we've sponsored to come here and tell
them a little bit about the kind of
company that we are kind of work that we
do and why we passionately believe that
these great scientists should consider
coming to a company like Mars for a
lifetime career in fun science that will
make the world a better place best part
really is that you get to actually meet
these young scientists who will look at
you in the eye and say this is the best
week of my life
it is Sigma the Nobel laureate and have
a conversation that is a gift so we have
a science breakfast which is the
opportunity for us to host the
discussion around a very meaningful area
of research of healthy aging so we have
Liz Blackburn who won a Nobel Prize in
this field and we put her together with
a group of young scientists in the forum
facilitated by ourselves let's think
about the huge amount of years that
human lives are right so I made little
scale bar for you on this high-tech
thing here this is a time scale what's
the maximum I've spent over a worm it
goes from here to here right of a fruit
fly from here to here now things get a
bit better okay let's go all the way out
to a mouse all right keep going keep
going okay we've got up to kindergarten
we've got decades and decades of life
the science breakfasts are always great
fun highly interactive and a really good
way to have meaningful debate in an area
of public interest but also interest to
ourselves we're in middle age here so
maybe somebody's getting some diabetes
now I mean that's the thing it's not
just your life span this perhaps years
of living with chronic disease I think
you get the point right I'm just
constantly struck by how we have to be
thinking in terms of enormous timescales
that these things are the world is going
to be facing an aging population we're
all going to get older and there's going
to be a lot more of us who are old how
do we deal with that helping young
scientists realize that they can work
with somebody and realize that these are
problems that the world has to solve and
business and science can do it together
I think the private sector can play a
real role because this sort of research
that can be done by a company that isn't
necessarily related to just the
quarterly bottom line is the kind of
research that's complementary to what
governments can find and I think Mars is
a good example of that so we got 37
Nobel laureates here and just over 600
young scientists and if we can play our
role in catalyzing some of the magic
happening between those two groups of
people then we go away very happy
you